good evening four deaths on Valley roads
last night within hours of each other
police reporting one crash killed two
people visiting town on Fremont Street
and it begs the question what can be
done to keep people safe while they're
celebrating New Year's Eve thanks for
joining us at six I'm Denise Valdez and
I'm Brian Loftus and tonight we are
getting a first look at the woman
accused of driving drunk then killing
that couple Victoria Saha is here with a
look at the efforts to keep pedestrians
safe on the holiday
Fremont Street will be one of the
busiest places on New Year's Eve with
people packed into the quarter many
trying to cross the streets but as we
saw last night Crossing when you aren't
supposed to can have deadly consequences
which is why crowd control is a big
priority
Fremont Street an area where it draws in
a big crowd no matter what time of the
year it is
but on New Year's Eve that will
intensify we want to be visible and
folks are going to know we're out there
and same with Las Vegas Metro chief of
Public Safety for the city of Las Vegas
Jason Potts says the deadly hit and run
Wednesday night on Fremont Street was a
reminder of how quickly things can take
a turn our folks you know were the first
ones there and they they performed CPR a
44 year old man from Minnesota and a
51-year-old woman from New Mexico were
killed while crossing Fremont at 4th
Street police say they were crossing
Against The Pedestrian signal when 28
year old Mikhail Terrell drove into them
took off but was arrested a short time
later Chief potts's team has launched
operations safer where City Marshals
will be on the grounds to prevent any
tragedies leading up to New Year's Eve
we'll have a lot of folks out there a
robust presence and we'll have them at
the major intersections I see it all the
time people just be careful vendor
Michael fox says he isn't surprised by
Wednesday's tragedy but wishes visitors
would follow the rule stop at the
stoplight for two minutes wait your turn
cross while there earlier in the day I
saw plenty of people crossing when they
weren't supposed to one close to getting
hit
Chief Potts says this tragedy is a good
reminder that rules apply here in Las
Vegas no matter where you're from if the
cross signal is red then have some
patience and wait your turn to cross he
also says there will be plenty of
officers in uniform and without but due
to safety reasons he couldn't give me
the specifics on how many will be
patrolling Fremont Street